the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and Welcome to our
broadcast of the summer chess classic I
I am Yasser and I'm here with Vegas
wow we have been having a lot of fun the
ranks have been going just like that and
the action is fantastic let's jump right
into it and tell us about the standings
absolutely group a beg them do the
honors A standings when we ended the
broadcast yesterday it had to look
differently of course unfortunately
Benjamin lost his game which was totally
winning against per nap and now
pronounced it's starting to force with
Nicholas Theodore and Benjamin is right
behind them with two and a half points a
shock turn around for sure tell us about
the standings in the group b Group B so
far Andrew Hong and Akshay Chandra they
are tying to force with three and a half
points out of four and they're having a
great tournament both of them and Simeon
lamassov is right behind them with three
points blazing hot scores in that group
and tell us about the format for these
two events this is two 10 player round
robin tournament 90 minutes for the four
sporting moves and 30 minutes for the
rest of the game with 30 seconds
increment throughout the game
nice and the schedule is pretty
straightforward but absolutely let us
know what's happening we have games
every day no rest days and then today is
round five and we might have if it's
necessary playoffs in the end of the
tournament wonderful tell us uh tell our
audience what they can expect from the
pairings for today's game let's start
with Group B
as you as usual we have great players
and every day it's exciting to watch all
of the games but we have our key matcha
which is nishnik versus pronounce it
they both are great players and it's
absolutely going to be a stunning game
Ilya is drawn all of his games pranav of
course one of our tournament co-leaders
let's just take the gander at the
position uh currently on the board and
Black's last move was the move Knight D7
I've often talked about this when a
player is facing a pawn storm one of the
best ways of facing the pawn storm is to
get out of the way
just now he played he played G5 and okay
White's just expanding getting some
space you'll likely want to follow it up
with H4 H5
always in these kinds of positions where
the rook and the queen are on the same
file you always have to look at the jump
Knight D5 a move earlier it didn't work
take it take it now
exactly you you think okay I got a
really nice pin going on
the queen is unprotected if the queen
were protected for example by the bishop
there would be Rook takes and this
combination would work as it as it
stands
the result and exchange down
is actually slightly better for for
black nonetheless it's something that
you think about and you always always
have to be carefully attuned to the move
Knight D5 tell us about the pairings for
the I'll get it right this time B group
we have very young talented players but
today our key matchup is La Masa versus
Andrea Hong
Andrew Hong is leading with three and a
half points and Simeon is right behind
him with three points it's going to be a
great game for sure interesting line
scores samyang starts 2-0 Andrew has
done the hat trick though won his last
three games let's jump into that game
and let's take a gander at what's going
on there
um
when we were just coming into Studio
doing the rehearsal and exactly at this
point I was expressing the idea that I
like white I like the extra space I like
this pin and I hate being in pen so one
of the things I might have been
agreeable to is to trade some pieces of
off the board including the queen
and accept just accept the fact that I
have one weakness
uh
but as I told you yeah they're Fighters
Andrew wouldn't exchange the pieces
right the other thing that I have to be
again as black I'm always incredibly
sensitive to these exchange sacrifices
and now we can see the players on our
screen oh yeah interesting and just a
second Let me refresh my board and uh it
seems like we do have some more moves
yes we do I apologize Bishop takes E6 F
takes E6 D4 okay let's go takes tags E5
let's go by the way
one of those tactics that you know you
know he wants to exchange
winning a bond
rookie one
takes takes and we've caught up with the
players and
I'm gonna say I'm I as far as Andrew's
concerned I think black has accomplished
his goals in the opening he's got a safe
King he's got his fair share of the
center and his pieces are effectively
developed maybe this Rook will slide
over no and then everybody right because
it's not doing anything right on d8 and
I think everything's uh okay these
players have been fighting hard yeah
let's be very very clear we've seen some
great clashes what are they fighting for
start with group a absolutely we have
great prize funds for the tournaments
and group a first prizes six and six
thousand dollars second prize is four
thousand and third prizes three thousand
and rest of the tournament also gets
prizes with the total price fund of
twenty two thousand dollars pretty nice
very handsome and tell us about the
group b Group B first prize is four
thousand dollars second prize is two and
a half and third prizes two thousand
dollars with the total prize fund of
fourteen thousand and all the players
are gonna get some prizes nice very nice
thank you uh St Louis chess club and
there we see a view of the playing Hall
the St Louis chess club is going
undergoing um
Chase yeah construction they are
actually just playing down the street
very closely there you see the man in
the lavender
shirt walking by is I wonder who he is
he's part of our production team
he's not working hard
it seems like he's just taking time out
stand in front of the cameras what are
the producers for he just wants to be on
screen yeah I think so I think that was
what it was all about
beg him let's jump into the game
absolutely uh we'll do we'll deal with
our marketing first also we have a
result of today
yes
I am truly upset about London I don't
know what's going on I hope he's doing
all right unfortunately he lost his game
against elshon which was a quick game as
well let's take a look exactly well
Linderman actually had won this event I
believe in 2022 so he he loves sports
and he loves playing in St Louis Bishop
B5 check okay so elshon kind of plays
wow boy I I should know it's like the
Nota boom variation but a reverse so uh
it's from a kind of a Queen's Gambit
accepted where white gets these two
protected past pawns on the queen side
black gets these uh two Pawns in the
center and the imbalances are really
really uh Sharp
G5
oh dear
I hope it was his preparation but as
Karchner said yeah sir yes
I think everybody and his brother has
played Bishop D6 here usually you don't
want to commit the pawns too soon but on
a good day what you often try to do is
go E5
he's tilted well uh
[Music]
I don't think it's terrible and I I
actually even think that this has been
played before I've seen these kinds of
very sharp moves in similar positions
the problem is always always always I
say it constantly time after time you
have three goals that's all just three
goals in the opening don't get stressed
about this or that you have three goals
you want your fair share of the center
you want effective development for your
pieces and you want a safe King so when
you play the move G5 it literally
number three goes out the door because
guess what you are not castling in Queen
side you do not have shelter there
you're not castling uh King side you
just played the move G5 your King's
gonna stay in the center and it's it's a
responsible decision I just want to say
G5
and now I'm confused if you're going to
play G5 I would have thought that the
follow-up was intended G4 the problem is
at Knight E5 and I'm threatening Knight
C6 and then 97 of them exactly I'm
almost forced to take take
well I
I'm I'm playing for development even I
can go back right right of course it
should be too much I I assume
um you don't want to trade or trade so
Bishop B2 and what am I supposed to do
am I supposed to play I mean
but
if I play G5 why did I play why didn't I
play G6 I agree with you I if I play G5
you need to follow up right so he didn't
that's why I have a feeling either he's
like missing he cannot remember his
lines or he's just tilted and he's just
making you know especially when you get
tilted In classical tournament that's
the most horrible thing it ever can
happen right uh
wow okay again I find the move Queen C7
uh rather puzzling now that you've
um how do you say a gain control over
the E5 Square so that the Knight could
not hop to E5 once again G4 and I'm not
saying I I'm a fan of Black's play but
I'm saying that it seems like the
consequence uh consequential decision
Queen C7 well elshon had seen enough he
said let me take the pawn the difference
now that he's included Queen E2 and
queen C7 is he's got this clever little
move and any hits means that G2 is
covered you don't win back the pawn I
think black's in trouble okay Linderman
has put Bank on the break E5
maybe times a castle Yeah uh pause here
for just a second and once again we go
back to our three uh goals of any
opening you know
uh
Center control
uh uh effective development King safety
uh
that's it that's just it King wow King
f8 oh my goodness
uh
if it's his preparation
if it's preparation it ain't great uh
uh I think I'm going to take take King
f8 at least in this that's the idea
ID I've got at least plans of
um and Bishop before is the threat as
well exactly rookie eight Bishop F4 D5
D4
King f8 okay well we know uh Alex has
lost the game yeah so but maybe it could
be his still preparation and he just you
know messed up in
this move looks crushing uh why uh the
idea is as simple as it looks I just
want to take the palm
I want to take the pawn and I want to
play Queen F3 that's it Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5 Queen F3 thanks to my uh
play on this diagonal
F7 is a weakness
seven is if you take on F4 actually
you're opening up e diagonal e and then
I can actually click on D5 maybe after
taking and the idea is that Knight H7
and then force you to walk into a very
nasty uh I'm not sure if if it works
like that but I could take an F4 first
threatening 95 97 if it just uh which is
a Checkmate uh the problem that I'm
having here is white
is I don't want to see the move d4 so
for example hold on when when when did
we take on if we take immediately here
and you know what I'm saying there's no
the absolutely I understand but I'm just
saying the idea right yeah of course of
course uh this looks terrible it takes
on F4 takes on D5 as advertised well it
just happened that way sorry I mean I
don't think we're winning this
completely oh my gosh I think it's
terrible he didn't take that I find that
interesting he played Queen F3 oh takes
Knight E7 that makes sense okay Queen F3
immediately I thought after taking it
yeah but this is
same principle
you're getting killed on the diagonal
any night landing on B6 is going to
invite A5
Queen B7 that's crazy how we predicted
the game right now
oh even more uh
terrible the Knight actually comes I
thought B6 pardon me I thought you were
going to hit B6 with the move A5 but
Knight F6 is with a Tempo
check and by the way that resigns on the
spot no and then he makes fast I don't
know what is going on with London run
he's just as you said on tilt and uh it
feels like it sometimes you have this
lightning bolts that just strike and you
just have this beautiful streak and you
go oh wow that was wonderful how do I do
it again
sometimes you get the uh you know yeah
everything is Right terrible and that
was terrible okay it feels like his
opening ideas are not working and his
game like his mindset is not there uh it
seems like uh Alex isn't definitely uh
not doing very well I'm just going to
refresh the board here I was going to go
to ilia's yes Ilias game so
uh let's go back we left it after G5
boom
Rook E8
Queen F2 now to me when I see this move
Queen F2 by the way it absolutely
absolutely telegraphs the move Knight D5
is on uh White's agenda I love playing
such positions as white because you like
space I love space especially when you
can attack and they cannot right tell me
about the move Queen F2 do you find that
move attractive I do uh as you said
Knight D5 is coming right and I'm
controlling the black squares better
okay I was probably preparing if H4 H5
and even in some cases maybe a five F5
is H4 H5 F5 yeah okay so it's just like
better coordination after rookie eight
you don't want to have your King on E2
anyways right your queen on E2 vis-a-vis
The Rook yeah uh but okay so but okay
what I'm really asking you begum is long
term you you like space if you like to
attack so let's do it let's go right
like but why does Queen F2 in your mind
I fit into your attack what is it about
the move Queen F2 do you say I'm going
to go Queen F2 to H4 did you should I
have a game like I put to maybe Queen G4
on F2 and then I played 90 to 90 tonight
F5 for H5 it was like it was one of my
favorite games and still is because Tori
Eugene Torres yes from the Philippines
Grandmaster I adore him as a person
right I was so excited to play him and
we had similar script structure I was
like I'm doing these things and it's
working right and slowly I started to
like you know beat him and then my
calculations work I'm like there's no
way because I was so excited to play him
I didn't even like imagine winning that
you would win yeah he's just like one of
the best yeah you know
first Asian Grand Master absolutely by
the way in case you didn't know this one
of the great singers in the Chess World
Eugene Torre has an incredible voice
really yeah he serenaded me in Hyde Park
in London and he sang to me uh Frank
Sinatra's My Way
I was overwhelmed it was so good I
didn't know that we have very close
relationship with him and then his wife
she's lovely too yeah yeah uh I like
your move Queen G4 which perhaps as you
said 92 Knight G3 and let's go
uh I find the move Queen F2 strange uh
for the very simple reason that I don't
know if
E2 is a better Square than F2 so in my
mind I would play a move like H4 H5 and
later I will determine whether or not G4
or F2 or gosh knows maybe G2 I mean it's
a strange thing
exactly and also a rook lift right so
for me the move Queen F2 is a little
puzzling Queen B8 now this again the
feeling is just like trying to control
B6 Square I don't know why or C5 now
becomes C5 sometimes in these positions
even the engine can say oh you should do
this you should do that the problem is
that if you uh if you are too aggressive
you can end up after D5 or E5 or B5 you
can end up in a totally uh bad position
yeah uh again we talk about telegraphing
your moves right so I I sidestep Knight
85 but for me black is saying I want to
play B5 so let's uh let's see what
you're going to do
wow look at this oh that was his idea so
he's putting the queen on F2 so he can
attack with the E Pawn and then just
exchange it
yeah okay
um
okay I boy I I tell you I would be very
very reluctant to handle this night uh
something like this and you know playing
a position like this would suit me a
little bit better like usually I don't
like doing it with the nights like that
and the structures usually you don't you
don't have anything to attack with after
Knight needs to go to F5 he took he took
and uh this acceptance is challenged
right extends the diagonal of the bishop
on G2 now this version is better the
problem was without if you don't take it
Knight can stay on D5 because anytime
you take I take with the e-pawn and then
you your Bishop stuck there on C6 okay
but let's say just a a another
perspective let's say I play B5 well
then I can take it on E7 okay and we
take
so take take
I like such positions the six weakness
without the bishop it's always good yeah
no I don't have to attack you I can go
Queen D2 Queen to D2 I'm not sure b b c
b c maybe just and how are you is B tech
support how are you to like defending
defending the B5 uh D6 let's say
uh I I can do it on this success no I
know I just uh
checking out the resulting position I
don't think I can use the beef you want
to trick me I do that I do desperately
in fact
uh Knight C5 isn't working either no the
pawn on D6 is frankly uh too weak in
this uh variation all right he has taken
taken Bishop A4 okay give me that said
Ilya he's trying to get the squares
Knight C5 F5 now the inclusion of the
move makes a great deal of sense if the
queen was in E2 Bishop G5 would be
embarrassing yeah
and now from White's point of view he's
a pawn up he has the two Bishops and
he's eyeballing F6 F6 if it lands on the
board well we can sign score sheets
pronounce being too optimistic about his
position here
well just a second uh
but but black has a argument black is an
argument Black's argument is I'm playing
on the dark squares kind of like a
checkers game if you will playing on the
dark squares and I'm trying to limit the
scope of your Bishop let's see if he's
right I sure he did a great move which
is 97 and Knight comes to E5 and as we
talked earlier if you push the pawns you
can create many weaknesses now after H4
um
can we go I'm kind of confused he played
the move Knight C5 only to play two
moves later Knight back to D5 night back
you just wanted to
why to play F5 and H for now G4 as we
talked earlier if you play H4 your
weakening the king weakening the squares
so
uh just he's trying to trick his
opponents okay age for 97 Queen G3 and I
guess that's it let me just uh double
check by uh refreshing my board and uh
tell me your
your take what do you think about the
position
still like white because anytime I can
play Bishop F4 or Bishop D4 and take on
E5 I don't see any reason to object
absolutely yeah okay like it's always
worst case right when you think about
the position you're always like okay
worst case I can do that well in fact
let's just make a bad move for black
okay just just so we can see what we
might be talking about a minute and C5
is always possibility C5 if I for
example I put uh put a rookie one then I
want to take on F6 and play C5 suddenly
you're you have weaknesses there
absolutely and two Bishops we appreciate
that we do indeed so we just feel
ourselves that Ilya is for choice and uh
by the way Bishop D4
I think we have a different move let me
just uh again I'm just going to make a
quick yeah Bishop to d8
okay so
that is
cheeky cheeky do you do you like this
word cheeky yes
okay Bishop D4 we sidestepping Rook
takes E3 yeah he wants to trick him into
like
exchanging on B6 but still putting a
knight on the E5 somehow and protecting
F6 right it's overwhelming for black in
my opinion
opinion you cannot combine all the like
ideas and then make weird moves like
that sorry which Bishop d8 you you sorry
say say that again
I like this or not
these ideas to play
B6 I like it but like at the same time
he needs to protect F6 and then he
cannot attack with the Knight because
Knight should be on E5 even after the
exchange you cannot immediately play to
E5 because F6 is hanging right so if you
take on G5 then Knight E5 squares is not
as strong as it was so he he's trying to
combine all the ideas to make it work
that's why he played B5
he wants to play Bishop B6 and Tech with
the queen right
B5 but boy which creates another problem
yeah right uh you know my mind is racing
because whenever
it's a very simple principle you have a
Pawn on D5 yeah
what squares do the pawn attack
C6 and E6 because I have a Pawn on D5
I think oh my my natural Outpost smart
B6 and C6 if I could post a rook on C6
or if I could place post a rook on C6
I'm golden right and also we need to
remember that he's Pawn up and actually
to begin with so when I see this mode B5
the first move that I look at is takes
takes and post The Rook on C6 I think
that the Rook is like like uh super
thing I would play that and then
wouldn't mind him taking on A4 but
exactly Elia took it with a pawn first
okay he's being a little bit greedy
about that well I mean he worked hard to
get his extra phone he wants to take and
he took it back yeah and now here's the
moment of truth that's probably he will
immediately take oh no he decided to
think
well let's have a look-see takes now
again Queen takes anything that oh sorry
The Rook is hanging so you have to trade
on EU on C1 first and most probably
he'll play Bishop B6 exactly because his
idea takes takes just can't be what what
what what what uh pranav has in mind so
he must be intending to move Bishop B6
he's still trying to play for the
weakness of G5 H4 pawns yes I think he's
going for for the king for the king yes
uh White definitely lifted his kimono on
the king side there by playing G4 G5
okay well I don't know it's it's two
pawns is it worth two pawns I I am a
little skeptical
logic says it shouldn't work and then
you're threatening like exchanging the
pieces and you're not threatening as
much exactly uh just upon was here for a
second because
I I really do like White's position but
I think he's cashing in his chips a
little bit too early one of the things I
really like about White's position is
the two Bishops and I'm
in some ways I would rather avoid
trading the dark Square Bishop if I can
and once again let me just see this move
if I take
maybe he will take on C1 yes I guess so
I guess take on C1 and maybe I mean if
you want to take my desire was to kind
of to stop you from playing Bishop to B6
maybe it's this mode Bishop B6 that is
annoying me I just
I hate
um
so I'm going to refresh the board and
I'm just going to say Ilia currently two
pawns up but I think after Rook C1 oh he
can play immediately we should be six I
don't know why we didn't consider that
uh once again I
think it it's about this posting move I
think he wants to keep the Rooks though
that's black yes okay
don't you think so I don't know I I I I
I I don't have uh my grip on the
position I don't feel the players as
much as we do right exactly yesterday
pronounce was making all the moves I was
suggesting and go to the losing position
but well you look like that
I saw a game Let's jump to the game of
Nicholas for a moment and uh one of our
co-tournament leaders he's up against
is white and Nicholas is black so far
Aram is not having a great tournament
but not having a bad tournament either
he drew his all of his games yeah he's
playing a very solid chess and it feels
like he's
uh down a pump but he's he has some
pressure because Knight comes to G6
threatening Rook f8 Checkmate exactly it
feels like he has an he has enough
compensation to make a throw again
just well well let's go I I suppose we
have to play takes A7 right okay
that one I didn't like because of my B5
correct
um the problem with Rook takes A7 is you
give up your um beautiful beautiful
checkmating patterns either with Knight
G6 to h8 made or maybe rationally just
taking and playing Rook A4 would be fine
but like I don't want my opponent to
activate all of the pieces rookie 4 for
example yeah and you can go back tonight
after three but
well then you're kind of on the back
foot a little bit I don't know if that's
what
around once yeah if you had in mind all
right we'll keep an eye on that we're
going to go to the game of John Burke
Mishra do you like
um
chest variants
the the like do you like to play for
example losers chess or suicide chess or
Atomic actually I do not no bug house
for you no no I love Bach house it's
just like uh just to play with us for
fun of course and then during one of the
tournaments recently it was our
production team I was working at the
Juniors and seniors they offered me to
play on leeches me without knowing I'm
just playing and I asked them guys
what's this apparently it's like you
need to put the King on the center and
this is yeah yeah
here we go I'm like where are you going
is it okay
[Music]
good good get them I think they are very
very fun and I remind you loves those
things I do too and uh the reason I
asked you is because I like a variant
called crazy house in that very end when
I capture one of your pieces now I
captured your Bishop yeah so now it's my
bishop and I can turn this captive
Bishop into my Army and I can use it and
one of the things in uh in crazy house
chess is this a queen on D1 and that
very often you want to trade pieces so
you can have them in your hand so you
make a move like Knight B2 and that's a
pattern that is very common in crazy
house and strangely enough it's not that
common in regular chess like how often
do you see a guy going Knight B2 forking
a rook on B on D1 and a bishop on D3 in
order to achieve this a trade of pieces
um in psychological level it feels good
right yeah you can make them anytime
you're pulling out a tactic okay let's
just take a look at this position John
Burke
with the white pieces has one two three
four five yes sir again two three four
he's a pawn up my favorite living
condition uh gets a little bit better
than that he also has two connected pass
bombs on the King on the queen side
that's got to be good one drawback is
the Knight on H1 we would rather that's
the question I wanted to ask how did the
ninth end up okay well let's let's add
you and it has been there apparently for
a while you ask and I will answer the
queen came
and captured the bond and drove the
Knight into this could I play Square F2
I don't know I don't know uh where do I
go with this guy
I don't know uh just King F2 but I'm
threatening Rook H1 okay all you do is
kick me home okay I I'm a pawn Grabber I
will keep the Palm maybe A4
I'm not that much a fan of what I just
did but okay oh now I can take on B flat
yeah you won your Pawn back
[Music]
happy life happy life
live long and prosper Knight takes B5
okay
I I'll fall for it
promise me Rook H1 by the way but you
didn't deliver you were you
controlling me actually now we can play
or I could play it before night B5 as
well but okay what what would you like
you don't play rocket Juan I will carry
that okay
um
Queen
where should the queen go okay Queen F4
we don't have any threads no no no no
maybe
one player went Knight B2 to take a look
now you're really to take a bishop for
me now you're gonna play Knight z7 to
take this bishop okay uh okay four wait
let's get it you go away you bother me
you bother oh I oh you bother me ah now
she starts
okay I got I got I got it no problem
what's that okay by the way we have to
promise our audience that we will be
sharp and we will maintain our Focus
because the other day you missed check
meeting oh my God yeah sir it was on you
oh my God that was terrible
I really it was I feel bad for you right
right my sh your shame I never mind it's
such a shame
and then guess what immediately after
the broadcast ended my friends texting
me saying yeah I was watching it and
then she's like for five minutes you
were like guys talking about stuff and I
was wondering if it's not made uh in one
or she was like am I missing something
right right that was such a shame we
haven't really had to cut it I'm yeah
we'll talk to the producers and when we
archive it's never related never never
too late okay this is how we uh by the
way I just heard from the producer
they loved it they were messing with us
they loved it they hit the D3 and this
is essentially
John sacrifices H fund to pick off some
Queen side pawns and Mishra is putting a
lot of stock into his uh attack but
I don't believe it I think he's simply
fighting to for survival here uh I if
I'm in White Shoes I'm very happy
to create a Target
by capturing any trades I feel white is
just winning yeah you know any major you
take off the queens and I get to
do you know my is it on your Spotify
list my hit song push him baby
do you know the song push him baby
I sang a song
baby
and it's on it's on Spotify really yeah
you can put it on your list I'm not
kidding no I don't think I get royalties
no the crazy part the crazy part I am
not kidding I'm in Germany I'm on ski
holidays and I'm waiting for my party to
come and join me because I'm too fast on
the skis I'm way too fast
and as people join me one guy he's
coming down the mountain with shorts I'm
not kidding and he's grooving like this
and he's got the biggest ghetto blaster
on his head that you can imagine and the
guys that's doing this and he goes
zipping past me and he has push him baby
on his music I I'm like what
he didn't recognize me because I'm in
goggles
I'm like the proverbial ice man this guy
is doing his thing it was yes it was
never mentioned this before
come on you should come to my parties uh
I'm always there but it's a force
measure everybody who comes to the party
has to the person I will make sure to
check that out and also apparently we
have a very interesting game going on
Roll neck versus Darius what's going on
here wait a minute I mean talk about it
and also as usual Darius has 35 seconds
left and then round like has 29 minutes
and as you as we saw earlier ronak plays
fast even if you lose the game he loses
fast
um okay so obviously that that this is a
wonderful position for explaining how
chess works
forget about positional forget about
strategy that has nothing to do with
this position this position is a
complete mess and it comes down to one
thing and one thing only and that's
calculation you just have to calculate
either why it's completely winning or
completely lost it feels like
uh these pieces are frightening and by
the way the last few moves you said 30
seconds so it looks like one of those
King's Indian defense games where black
has has indeed crash through on the king
side
but
getting to this position has cost him a
lot of material did he run out of
firewood sometimes you have an attack
where it's like you're just missing the
last key element you're just
like you're on
time to everything to work out for white
yeah once you play A7 and you draw this
Rook away from the attack
that's an indication to me that the
attack is a fail it just it it's a fail
it feels like black should have
something but if you as you said when
you start calculating yeah yeah there's
nothing so help me out here I'm a pond
Grabber so I want to ask a Salient
question Queen takes F3 what you gonna
do
81 Knight E1 is an option too thanks
this is not working Queen G1 is coming
back absolutely yeah
by the way we also have another one and
Darius had like five I'm sorry five
seconds that's why he had to make a
movie
so yeah we have another result let's go
there
our key matchup yes uh Andrea Hong
versus
white they made a draw
the last one
yes
yeah
we left it
five you know that's funny it wasn't
expected we've been we've been talking
about Knight takes D5 winning upon the
old you know uh Boomerang tactic getting
out of the pin by playing Knight takes
D5 we didn't see it in this version he
played D5
what what what what what
ah The Rook protects the the queen what
no what
okay now I'm really confused why didn't
he take the night
Rook f8 probably I should include and
then just take on D5
and then I don't think you have a mate
King H2
wow
[Music]
uh
normally speaking I don't invite my
opponents
it to force me to walk the plank
enjoy my king no thank you Ivy I'll keep
my uh business to myself
um what did I sorry once more I'm
missing maybe we're missing something
let's let's focus right down well okay
if you take on D5 immediately then Queen
E3 is coming right and that's Rook F2
then embarrassing
correct and that's just hopeless that
that loses so you have to take
now I take now your queen is hanging and
I have to take on et5 Queen E3
King H2 is pretty much the only male now
this gets me immediately a prepared but
this gives me a very scary how are you
making the professional Queen E5
check okay
King H1 mate yeah
yeah Queen E3 checks
uh he didn't do that I mean if you look
at fun maybe he had some chances I don't
see Perpetual for white and then it
feels like Queen on E3 and Rook on F1
seems great to me seems great to me too
uh takes takes takes takes
what the heck is this probably he missed
something he probably black thought this
position should be winning but they
forgot about something for sure probably
couldn't foreign
quite the Donna Donnybrook um Donnybrook
is an Irish word in the Irish bless the
Irish they have these marvelous
festivals but at these festivals
sometimes fisticuffs and it's a group
fight everybody
Donnie Brook and this was a bit of a
Donnie Brook uh something got missed but
uh yeah I I do believe Queen F4 that the
idea is to just Rook is hanging on data
authorized queen of Fate when he F5 is
coming it just uh sorry yeah I have to
show the people what you said Knight
takes D5 yeah no I'm saying that what
happened in the game Queen F4 was missed
by black otherwise black could go to
rookie for and queen E3 and rookie F1
position that we were talking about it's
very uh big and we're we're we're off
track here okay uh give me the move by
move uh what what what is it that you
want to say uh or put in the moves what
are you trying to
who missed what yeah I'm trying to tell
you that probably C4 and queen D4 Queen
F4 was the idea of the queen I I'm
pretty sure that he forgot that Queen f8
and queen that's it that's a perpetual
and then they're attacking it feels like
uh black thought that it's just like you
don't have any moves you cannot move the
king broken and queen he'll just keep
the pin and it's very important and most
probably otherwise as we talked about
black instead of Queen C5 they could go
to 95 idea so far we don't see anything
for
if you play Queen E4 which is a normal
look then I can check and play rookie
one
and drive the king further and try to
play it feels good yeah I mean I I I I I
don't like my king walking the plank and
yeah you're going up the board it feels
like we are not missing anything this
time you're right or are we blind yes
I'm worried about you
[Laughter]
no I
it but what a fight great and uh just
the kind of game we would hope for for
two of our leaders right yeah you know
like that they wouldn't make a a timid
tame draw I'm just going to the game of
but surren versus Justin Wang and we
have
well Bishops of opposite color but
that looks like a pretty healthy Pawn
unless
I don't have I was about to suggest
check and here I don't have that because
the bishop is coming this is uh I'm
gonna say I like White's chances of
winning this a lot of times we dismiss
Bishops of opposite color positions such
as making a draw but it was Rooks or any
other places it's always tricky it
depends who is controlling what's
squares absolutely uh jumping to the
game of Luca and Brandon
well oh it was a huge mess Brendan
started off g66 very ambitious you know
that was that was my I I did this so
often as a youngster I love to do this
as a black and or white I often play G3
with the idea of Bishop take C6 yeah so
you still play this with black against
me did I okay well you know I I I I I'm
telling you the truth and the idea
is not necessarily that I want to win
the uh the pawns no uh what I really
want to do is fix the queen side why
because I actually want to go King D7
and King season
right where since you don't have Knight
B5 check and you don't have Bishop A5
check and you don't have ways of getting
at my king my Kings rather safe and then
eventually I get to play for F5 let's
see how it un
unraveled Queen F6 this is all pretty
standard stuff at least for me for me it
was a surprise why would you play Queen
G7 Queen F6 but yeah it's preparation
for and then appearance you have to
defend h61
and to stop Bishop G5 in many occasions
now for the moment the immediate F5 is
not effective because the bishop on D3
means that the Knight on D7 is a little
bit in the way by the way King d8 is
another way of getting to C7
castles King yeah so it feels like you
prepared Brendan today
well or the worst of all possible worlds
Brandon's been studying
anyways it also means you prefer it a
generation is being ruined under my
watchful gays uh G3 G5 wow
what a game so F5 wow whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey things just uh heated up nights
are jumping around by the way that night
on G2 kind of makes a pathetic uh
appearance right it looks to me I would
prefer black to be honest me too me too
and I'm a pond grubber so that's saying
a lot oh maybe bishop A6 I'm not sure
then Bishop D3 right
well that's a problem okay you should be
six Bishop I kind of like that great
night yeah okay lovely takes takes
well we're still a pawn down but
I don't know these guys uh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
I'm not sure
a blunder I think
something went wrong here maybe no F3
Knight takes you maybe black maybe white
things
yeah well no question Knight takes C4
there's I got you if you dare play Queen
take C4 I'll grab that pawn on F2 and
grab the Knight on E3 and we are up to
date with the
we're far away it feels like
this is
my my brain do you want to take on uh
yeah
that's what that was my question Texan
F4
takes
uh I have to take this way I thought you
want to play rookie too but it wouldn't
work as well
I was probably Luca wanted to take on G5
to be honest with the pawn and show me
what you can
well I I I I I I will I'll be I'll I'll
set up a checkmate
Checkmate King B1
King B1
checkmate
can you see one no King Avon
King uh sorry King
Luke
F3 maybe I had to play Astro immediately
actually right I'll take your Rook yeah
but I take on e4 you take on G5 H6 Rook
G8 H7 it wouldn't work anyways it's an
extra piece uh none of this happened are
we missing anything yet what's going on
today we think Rook takes E3 and it's
such an obvious thing right
I mean you can take on check with the
queen with the Rook you gotta calculate
stuff right
we are missing something because it has
to be based on this I don't know oh yeah
he can take on E3 93.
King goes to D2 most probably
okay and then and then taking on G5 this
is scary
not for you why
I mean I'm a piece up G6
I mean pieces it's not working
pieces uh
maybe sorry maybe you you could go here
then you can take on
well wait a second I'm not on time uh
maybe this is what he was worried Rook
H6 yeah
oh no it's it's it's great stuff sorry
that we kind of let me just refresh the
board
and tell us where we're at because guess
what Knight takes ponte's Queen takes uh
Brandon said look your king is swimming
naked here what are you gonna do and
this looks really really good for black
as well I'm gonna ask us for the game
bran no matter how the result yeah and
like why don't you didn't you take on me
I will just text him yeah I'm just
curious well okay this move Rook E4
threatens two weeks to only move right I
was gonna say you know well I'm not a
fan but I I think that Queen absolutely
right yeah I have a feeling he's not
actually winning the game is it winning
might be because that's that's a big
majority four versus two and these two
pawns are they're probably they're not
falling that's the problem and then I
can beat gradient blue Rook H1 if you
play rookie five I play Rook G5
and then I'm threatening H6 how are you
dealing with this exactly how am I going
to deal with this uh probably
uh
uh with my usual greed
can I play H6 immediately yes I wonder
what a yeah
yes
age seven yes and you've got this guy
covered huh
gosh darn it
yeah maybe probably you're making it
you're not making Andrew actually no no
um weird stuff okay well let's see what
happened again I'm going to just refresh
the board apologies for that rookie four
what's the clock Times by the way
they're very yes
Luca it has six minutes unlike bradner
who has only 43 minutes he's 43 seconds
I'm sorry for these three seconds and
he's making moves on he's like the last
seconds basically and I have a feeling
he just wandered Queen yourself and
check
he forgot about it he must
or he very good question
for me both Queen G7 is a is a surprise
move because
it essentially sorry the move rookie 4
is a surprise move because it
essentially allows this trade of Queens
which I as black would rather not
absolutely I'd probably check on it
before and to escape it that's why I
have a feeling he would never do that
unless it's a blunder yeah I mean that
definitely you know that team he's so
nervous and we do have some moves on the
board so I'm just saying in this
position now he needs to make a draw
somehow I would I would find the most
King I would find the move King B6
attractive I would find the move Queen
before check though and I would find the
move rookie one attractive for example
let's suppose we just had this ending
I'm not saying I win it
a hundred percent of the time you know
King and Rook versus probably should
take on D1 oh probably yes I'm sure you
were right but it doesn't matter it's
this point maybe it would be even a
better choice check uh I'm not saying a
hundred percent I win it with black but
you know I
not sure I like this move rookie four I
think he's he's
messed up a little bit he messed this up
but if he's like cautious enough I guess
he still can stop the pawns on the H7 or
so then slowly play C4 Kings if I maybe
it's his idea that he was in time
trouble he didn't have time to calculate
so he decided to go to a little bit
Pleasant and again in his opinion okay I
don't think so we don't know we don't
know Rick H1 interesting move let's
check in with akshot
uh because uh oh I shot is struggling
big time uh maybe he's just simply lost
um I once lost this ending with these
double pawns against Roman jinji
hashvili it was a game that lasted
much longer like nine in those days they
had these time controls that kept going
nine hours uh they had these
adjournments okay they had these at
Germany oh that's good and I was
suffering throughout but I don't think X
shot is suffering because I think he's
just losing I mean he's got this uh
really uh
terrible night ending in front of him I
don't like this position at all let's go
back to our other
tournament yeah and pick up the pace
here because darouche
yeah
Queen takes F3 H5 ooh that's a very nice
move Queen F2 that's a very annoying
move I would say even you're playing and
your opponents keep finding the right
most and you don't have the attack and
you work on A8 you wish to have
different position basically right
exactly by the way this move uh by White
Queen G1 really a very very fine
defensive move Bishop takes G2 and I
think that's basically the darussus
bastard absolutely the nice trap the
Knight is trapped and you don't have any
tickles pardon me you don't have any
tickles on The Rook
because the night cover C4 and B1 well
they come back by
he was having a heart tough start and
somewhere something happened in one of
darusha's games earlier remember that
game where we were going to have dinner
with him and yeah it was like he played
like
he missed it and it was a good dinner
right yeah that was a really good
haircut okay so he not only did he have
a bathroom he didn't even get the dinner
that he deserved uh not good not good uh
let's go to the game of Ilia and uh
because when we left it Illy it was a
couple of Pawns up that we felt after
Bishop D6
I don't want to say there was sufficient
compensation but there was a kind of a
compensation going on here as you
mentioned
well played for Witnesses that's the
scariest part of like pushing the pawns
once the position is open opens it wants
the position opens up it's just like you
don't know what to do with it exactly
well that that that threat of Queen
takes H4 provoked Queen G3 and now it's
only one pawn and again the king's
safety the relativity of the Kings means
that there is a compensation
slowly black is trying to grab all the
pawns attacking the six G5 for H4
exactly but not easy to play it feels
like you shouldn't have any problems
playing white but like not easy to play
because you have to always like make
sure that you're not dropping anything
well indeed uh and again it's because of
this
um vulnerability of the uh King side I
thinking maybe it's wrong with me but
I'm thinking that White's last move in
by Ilya has invited a repetition I think
alien wants to go Roxy so
because he protected it okay good thing
about the White's position right now is
that I cannot move the Rook
from the back rank because you're
threatening Rook C8 and a G6
that's the help me help me help me if I
go rookie three for example uh you Rook
C8
you want to go like that then you're
like tied up totally well your turn
my turn your turn
hmm
your turn
give me your pawns baby oh my God
wait even if you take the pawn you're
still tied up like okay
[Music]
I mean you know I it's like it's a
little torture it's okay
okay one one little pin uh what you what
you gonna do I'm gonna take upon Queen
G3
but now you don't have that no yeah so
situations change I'm threatening I
think your King's more vulnerable than
mine Bishop F1 I'll keep playing
um shouldn't work it's one of those
positions
first but okay I will let you go yeah
it's one of those positions that you're
playing on the light squares and I'll
grant you that and I'm playing on the
dark squares and you know uh
I wouldn't be surprised by a repetition
by the way I wanted to go to the the
Mishra game because
baby
we left it no there was nights on the
board there were some nights on the
board check it out D4 E4 Knight F2 by
John
at night oh that was that's actually
that was a stunning maneuver by the way
that night got to the seafood remarkable
it's nice right made it out right and by
the way uh but we never want to allow D4
and E3 so Mishra
who wow I was about to say
went through the U.S Juniors unscathed
but he looks in terrible Straits right
now
as he's desperate uh to try to make a a
porpet but Dr B7 C6 I don't think so
do we go no a check and queen hangs our
Rook right so all we've got to do is
trade a rook
I I think Mishra is in in Desperate Dire
Straits I just spent all of his like
energy
from the Juniors yeah it was I talked to
many Juniors and all of them complained
how stressful the tournament is exactly
because it's hardest to play uh when it
comes to like people who know you well
and then your age group they always know
you are right and Junior is very
stressful yeah everyone was like it's so
stressful even girls like it's crazy
true and very unexpected results and on
top of that anytime those events that
are qualifiers yeah for something like
the national championships you know the
stakes are so much higher that you feel
that nervous energy and yeah I think
Mishra is suffering from the fact that
he probably put his heart and soul
absolutely it is the Juniors and he
doesn't have enough energy by the way we
do have a result not unexpectedly darush
uh final position
we left it about these parts Queen G1 we
thought it was over and
no more no no tricks no tricks no tricks
I mean
on the graveyard
of the king's Indian defenses you know
like you know they're they're bad things
happen to the dragon bad things happen
to the Catalan bad things happen
everywhere but in the graveyard of the
king's Indian
there's these epitots on the headstones
and they say the attack failed
you know why did you lose
failed what we've got here is a failure
and it happens it came back it failed I
mean whenever I lose a game it's also oh
I feel yeah
you know when I lose a game
it's because I gave it a rest
I didn't resign just decided it was time
it was time to to give it a rest
we'll come back to it we'll come back to
it we've got out their headstones that
we can talk about B7 by John Burke on
the board as expected Ilya well
I think
Prana decided that maybe his King needed
now Ali is listening to me
dangerous
[Laughter]
what do you think what's going on here
with Ilya again he comes into this round
both undefeated but also without victory
in other words he drew all of his games
pranaf on the other hand he is in first
place type first and Ilya if he has any
Ambitions of winning first this is the
game that he has to do it what's your
take because he is very ambitious about
this game and then he saw yesterday how
pranath is playing like messy positions
and then he's not precise about them but
she's going to use it and so what do you
think after this move I'm sorry this
last move rook d8 and it's important to
note that it's move forward a yes so he
will get another like 30 minutes and
he's gonna push it till the end okay uh
tell me what you think white should do
here I was thinking about Bishop C6 okay
I was wondering
if you play like Knight E5
I'm I'm really really really scared
exactly and then if you don't have a
Perpetual which you do not
I'm I'm I'm really into the game yeah
I'm really scared to allow that here I
would however toss in a chat exactly
that's the most crucial move okay H2
Queen D2
check right keep probably Queen E2 is
more precise so after King H3 you can
check on F1 okay King H3 Queen F1 King
H2 Queen E2 yeah you can take on F5 as
well yeah I was just saying that yeah
and that's the huge problem of it and I
have so you play Bishop C6 but now you
can go Bishop back to G2 and you go okay
uh you put your queen maybe on a square
that's not so useful but Queen B2 is is
my concern a little bit many people but
like if you play Queen B2 maybe I can do
something sorry let me just refresh
sorry so we're looking at Bishop C6
but Bishop C6 invading Queen D1 does
black really have a thread at the moment
maybe it's useful I think black wants to
play Queen E5
that's a question do you want to play
Queen E5
like
okay I can understand that maybe you
want to play Queen F5
uh
or queen takes G3 bit I think I'm just
trying to win the D6 Pawn I just I want
to exchange on G3 and play in Knight E5
and then you cannot so I take on F6 in
that case and I take the H7 Pawn
D6 and then probably that that's not
enough so what we're talking about
everybody is something of these nature
where where begum says I take on on D6
and I probably make a draw because I've
got a good
blockade and I I don't disagree
um
I mean it's a tune I can't even improve
it like take on G3 then take on G5 and
then play Knight E5 is that it
is that an improvement let's say I wait
just I'm just putting in
are you sure that you can afford this
yeah I'm pretty sure
because King F4 is not working at D3 and
Rook D6 so
King F3 is no King F4 is not working
because of Knight D3
hmm
okay
uh spidey sense is tingling a little bit
there just a game I haven't seen in a
little while Benjamin bot versus sassy
by the way we have another result yes in
group b tell me about it but Turin just
defeated Justin one Justin is having a
crazy tournament as well he's getting
the positions and then somehow
those positions are not going his way
and also he just ended the Juniors yes
also this is those exhausted Junior
players yeah
um Knight B3 love it no problem at all
no problem at all I'm I do feel a little
cramped though for black I would be more
aspiring towards the move C5 because I
think after d takes C5
I feel more comfy I'm ready to play you
know Bishop take C5 he did not do that
he played Knight B3
G5 well everything oh finally C5 thank
you
D5 is this well time
oh I mean
alert alert there's a there's a thanks
uh combination uh we had um in my time
in the Chess World a guy by the name of
Emery Tate and Emery was very very
famous for saying I
owe tactics
and here we go uh the tactics
are coming are coming by the way Queen
takes C4 just oh just let me play Queen
a very unpleasant position for plot I'll
show you my checkmating ability
uh no this has gone wrong this has
definitely gone seriously wrong now we
stop and we just say two Bishops
uh dominating the open file
this dark Square Bishop all it needs so
many weaknesses even like yeah I can't
afford probably to try transfer my
Bishop from E3 to like
once it gets on the phone diagonal you
know forget about it it's it's because
D6 is not actually hanging because we
should
wow
but we saw that he kind of made it to
the
I think somehow
uh why cashed in his chips way too early
I thought he would get far more than he
did yeah wow I mean that attacked that
that just looked really promising and
Justin yeah this was the one where we
left it I I still like White's chances
of winning but the problem is that the
pawns are falling yeah that seems that's
oh you get the pawn to E7 you can give
it a rest yeah yeah that's just two
that's just too powerful this is a
brutal game I would say oops
yeah you feel like you all almost made
it out almost protected your like
position and then you're doing kind of
well and it's not enough I I had one of
those games uh Anatoly karpov with great
great great player
Anatoly played brilliantly I mean he
really played in my opinion one of the
great masterpieces strategic
masterpieces around around move 36 I
thought I was going to resign
been in the last four moves of Crime
Control he spoiled it terribly and I
fought my way back to what I thought was
an even position we adjourned the game
then in the second time control we
completely outplayed me once again and
he won the game power to him Bravo
but it was one of those games I felt I
lost it twice
it wasn't enough to lose it the first
time around I needed to lose it the
second timer
he traumatized me
there's many players let's jump to Luca
and Brandon because that was that hey
and look we got a kind of a deal
yeah okay look at this this seems like
Brandon is not risking anything right
and also yes sir our players are here
well let's do it I got an interview
we'll miss you baby I'm sure big time
Big Time as uh we get uh set for an
interview I'm just looking at the game
of uh Luca and Brandon Jacobson
obviously
uh Brandon has at least a Perpetual in
his pocket but thanks to his King as
well maybe he even has ideas of setting
up mating Nets
like for example a bad move for white
just a terrible move for white takes
takes
uh and let's say C4 another terrible
move for white H7 or maybe it's not so
terrible I was uh about to play King
here in King here but I don't have it
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome
how was it today tell us about your game
here uh just a second no this was uh
yeah what uh what happened
yeah it was I think I was completely
winning at some point but I kind of
messed it up so bad
unfortunately I got back in track it was
not not perfect but it's crazy take us
through the game uh
yeah
at what point does your preparation
rather stop or
yeah kind of after E4 I just I just knew
the positioning position is completely
playable and
then I just want to play I mean it's
just simple chest right no no deep
preparations just there's no Minds
playing chess exactly and this is one of
those positions where both sides have
every right to say I'm winning I look I
have this very great great attack and
the other but I'm a pawn up and uh you
like these types of uh double-edged
games 95. okay tell me when you think
something happened
it was a surprise for me uh right here
the move Knight B3 was a little bit of a
surprise if I'm in black shoes I'm more
or less anxious to resolve the center
what did you think about the C5 model C5
let me see if I was always there but
I think was your intention I think I
thought
maybe after D5 I mean I have to I have
to meet C5 always D5 otherwise I'm just
going to be worse right yeah then
it kind of looked like I had some attack
there so I just I just this was what you
wanted this was this was basically still
kind of the game position Yep this is
the position I want to play whatever I
think rookie
is also not so common yeah that's
recording I saw I saw some live Queen E8
I think Queen yeah somehow just getting
out of this yeah okay I played I played
some games with Queen C8 which is a
mistake because we want to bring the
Rook to d8 yes
[Laughter]
one of these Rooks is gonna get to d8 we
just don't know which one let's see what
happened in the game because it was
certainly an exciting game and we
thought that
it was amazing that Justin could fight
his way to Bishops of opposite color
uh I think we just kind of came in
around these parts and we thought
wow you're certainly winning yeah yeah
and uh maybe maybe this move is just
not needed at this exact moment maybe uh
all you need to do actually is just
obviously get yeah along diagonal and
then the question is how to how to get
on that one diagonal
uh did you feel at this point that you
had this game in the bucket yeah I I
know for sure I was meaning
I thought I mean there's much easier way
to win I'm sure I'm sure there is what
there is but exactly yeah
it feels like I mean you've got
everything ready to go right yeah like
my pieces are just completely dominating
but it'd be maybe even Bishop B6 is not
neither maybe maybe even 86 was not
maybe not I love everything you did
right up to this point if you don't mind
a first suggestion to my mind is uh the
bishop on E3 just needs a a a better
life but I'm afraid well afraid is
strong I mean I'm afraid that that that
that that that the open G file could be
a cause of counter play but if I put the
bishop on G3 yeah then I can say F5
now it makes sense
it just feels like you know the moment
you play E5 and well okay
if it really is going great okay uh but
okay maybe you spoiled it a little bit
Yeah I completely missed it ah that was
my question did you yeah I did miss you
what happens to you when you feel that
moment like oh no yeah did you did you
panic yeah of course yeah after I played
Bishop C5 I got up and
to get some drink or snacks and then I
just kind of realized there was some
deflections
oh there's some Bishop T for kind of
deflection and I just I just thought
there's no way there that's going to
work again and I mean it worked but it's
kind of a Black's only chance I guess
yeah which I completely missed that yeah
by the way it's very very good that you
weren't at the board at the time you
realized your blunder because sometimes
you're at the board and you look
and you give your opponent a kind of a
tell right like but now you're you know
in the back and you're taking a drink
and oh dear
he doesn't see your reaction yeah like I
was completely expecting that exactly
exactly this is all a part of the
program
good for you takes takes check
and you're in this ending and how did
you feel did you you feel your chances
were high or you were a little were you
optimistic or pessimistic I was I was so
always optimistic about this kind of end
games but I'm sure if he somehow
get rid of the F6 Pawn without you know
messing up the position too much then he
had some serious chances to try to draw
but now there's some discordination with
the piece the pieces right well I when
we saw that you could get your Pawn to
E7 we thought okay then it's then then
it's too late and it's gone it's gone if
you had some kind of Fortress which
maybe if his Rook was on E6 maybe there
are some chances but I mean the best
Square for The Rook was on A6 but right
maybe
so somewhere back here if he if he had
somehow got his Rook to this E6 Square
then he could so did he ever have the
chance to do that then he threw in the
move Bishop F3 maybe this was just wrong
yeah it should be to maybe immediate was
what was better with the idea as you say
if he can get in the Rook yeah blockade
he's got some something going on yeah
Bishop D3 is coming also right so I have
to be careful about the E4 pound so
there's uh I saw some lines with yeah uh
King F2 Bishop D3 then King F3 I guess
yeah then my Rook is somehow stuck but
but also I have B3 at some point but yes
to undermine the bishop yeah that's
right it's still no fun for for black
attack I mean black is still uh on the
back foot but uh
yeah that's a shocking movement yeah
I messed this up so bad
could you recover thank you so much for
joining us and uh make sure you uh come
in uh again huh yeah absolutely share
your victories and we have more results
as Luca and Brandon did make a draw and
we think that Brandon let one slip away
we left it about these parts
and he did get the double Rook set up oh
nice move by Luca Rook takes C5 and a
draw was agreed because uh well we we're
we're gonna have to make a Perpetual
check
is it
I think so Jack
Ed
yeah very well repetition I mean ritual
check yeah we would call this a
repetition I'm just checking
just checking just checking just
checking
um
yeah I bet that was a funny yeah
we were talking about it it must be
easier he just missed it exactly exactly
that's a nerve-breaking moment oh
oh it sure is Chandra exchat's position
oh it's just so miserable I mean Justin
doesn't even want to see the position oh
no no it's it's like one of those your
pawned down yeah but your opponent has
the better pieces to begin with and then
it feels like your palm down and then
your position is bad still right it's
just like helpless but but also the the
real problem is as We Know
one of the things that you like to do is
contemplate you want some counters like
something that's the thing why and how
do you play when you don't know where
your counter play lies and you don't
even know what kind of a fortress you
would like clearly whitest white spawn
ons on E5 makes it very simple from
White uh all he needs to do is land the
Knight on the D6 square and it's a Splat
and it's game over so I do think the
harmonics
maybe H5 or not and then you just move
the king story can you eat three you
don't have a move
because immediately Knight to four
attacking on E6 right any cameras
all right so Night comes to F4 and it's
terrible uh let's check out uh the other
uh a group
yeah all right and as we're looking
we've got a uh very interesting position
uh against arush
yeah and uh well runic will join us uh
we've got Benjamin Bach
looks like Benjamin's suffering here as
this Pawn on H3 really is a nasty
and
Mishra in bad in in really bad shape
we're back hi welcome welcome to the
show come and take a seat
as uh I was explaining to the audience
that there's a very big graveyard
it's a very big graveyard and it's full
of headstones and it says it's the
graveyard for the king's Indian
you know and The Headstone says the
attack failed
yes because very often times of the
attack doesn't succeed well
strategically yeah it has it exactly
today you've played a very strong
opponent yeah tell us about your
thoughts going into the game
um the result so far wasn't so great
like I was on minus one so I was in a
fighting mood today right and seems like
he was also in a fighting mode he played
fairly fighting opening right E5
yeah instead of C3 actually I my file
had D4 I knew that but I couldn't
remember further so I decided to play
something more simple
right
and this position looked very standard
yeah instead of D6 oh I'm sorry so I
think he could take ed4
94 94. Bishop D4 and Bishop F6 but here
it felt like okay if someone is better
it's white exactly you can put your
Bishop on D five your knight on F3 yeah
or Knight on E3 in some cases yeah going
this way yeah that should be fine but
white can put some pressure
uh by the way just to clarify to
everybody this is uh the king's Indian
that I'm talking about once you get the
pawn to D5 and you get that that type of
structure very important move A5 tell us
why you like it too yeah I didn't even
consider any other move because Black's
threat is to play A5 and consolidate and
then he'll push F and I think he's
better so I have to push A5 exactly and
you kind of yeah but this Knight is in
big trouble right it's just like a
hovering in air and there's always a
possibility that you can cut off its
protection exactly okay F5 yeah Knight
D1 pretty standard queen yet F3 yeah I
didn't like Bishop H4 what did you think
he should do uh looks very tough already
because next move I want to copy ship C4
and protect the bishop protect the Rook
with the bishop and then I'm threatening
Bishop B6 and wrapping the Knight so I
didn't see what better he could do but
Bishop H4 somehow felt off okay
yeah it it it does have that feel that
whatever he does he's got to do it uh
bang bang uh for me I'm looking the
Knight on G6 and excuse me when I have
to say well the Knight on G6 sucks yeah
it's in the way the queen so if I could
make a suggestion for for
yeah here I was considering at least I
have Bishop F4 and E5 which is one
option but I wasn't sure if I would go
for this
and let's say instead of this the other
option was
like just make a move here
yeah because I don't really see a threat
uh queen wants to come to G6 yes
I did and there but uh one thing I
wanted to say about bringing the Knight
to F4 it's a rescue mission yeah exactly
I think it's the way how he should I was
I I I I'm I'm afraid that the Knight on
B4 right if I could get rid of the night
on B4 the night on E1
but Bishop H4 I think you're right I
think you've just pinpointed a moment
where
well uh this but I think practically it
wasn't easy for him like I had one R and
he had like one minute so he just
doesn't know what to spend his time
um from the opening yeah opening it was
he spent like 27 minutes or something
after like a very natural position
and then
where it is bent
control remember so much but tell me
where you think uh his last chance uh
yeah that was a very nice instead of
Knight F4 like Bishop even take Queen C3
Knight C8 like Knight F4 Knights yet ah
this night uh the D night the D night I
was considering this and Knight f8
actually works because Queen f8 yes I
have Knight B6
you know there was once uh I was
watching uh a game between Michael
gervich and granted as we had a
situation exactly like this
and
um Michael gurvich played the move King
G1 and at the same time said the Knight
can't move
it
forced him to resign okay uh it didn't
happen 93 Queen check
yeah I spent quite some time because I
was not so sure like if I go Bishop C4
also looks very standard but Knight H4
looked like it can muddy the waters a
bit okay so I chose Rook A2 very nice uh
defensive reaction along the second rank
yeah and uh apologies I have to speed us
up a little bit here but essentially
you're keeping Bishop on F1 just to
make sure there are no tricks but he's
that doesn't stop him he's coming you
know sometimes you have to you're
playing an opponent who refuses yeah he
has nothing to lose basically so he can
travel the tricks possible I think and
here he is trying everything he's
throwing he's throwing the kitchen sink
at you yeah Knight C4 was I think very
good just keeping everything together
well you you've certainly kept
everything under control at this point
the moment I saw rookie eight I thought
you know because you're taking away an
attacker very nice you kept your
composure uh
keep kept everything under control it's
what I would call a confidence building
victory yeah yes now four more games and
I'm still in the fight for the top place
so we're looking forward lovely how do
you like St Louis oh it's wonderful I've
been here once before yeah this is my
second time enjoying her yeah thank you
so much thank you for coming hope
hopefully you will see you more thank
you thank you and uh
let's just go to the game uh one of our
Marquee matchups Ilya
where are you you where are you Ilya ah
I shot no sorry I got the
I got the wrong uh tab open when we when
we left begum welcome back when we left
it you know Ilya was a pawn up but we
always thought that blackhead
well I want to say not full compensation
but it was going to be very hard yeah
good compensation and
foreign
we got this position
um I told you if you get it
yeah and this is this is a kind of a
fail because the problem is the three uh
Pawn Islands yeah you're not a fan of
taking on F6 yeah if this Pawn is on
from H4 is on G5 this bishop for
argument's sake is on H3 there's some
chances here this one I don't believe in
and by the way neither did Ilia because
they just stop right here there's a draw
agreed and it was a I think he started
to get scared of Knight ce5 Queen D6
this ideas yeah and also I print I've
had enough time to think about the
position and his chances and yesterday
he swindled yes yeah probably Ilya
didn't want that today right uh for uh
pranav I want to say this was a very big
test yeah uh he's black against in my
opinion one of the really really strong
players in the field exactly and uh you
know he survives and he puts him in
great contention uh in the championship
rounds uh I want to jump to Benjamin
Bach I don't like this position for
white uh this Alpha zero Pawn
why did I allow this Pawn exactly
and then if I'm able to like play G5 and
then F5 oh don't even think about it I I
just resign so here's the question for
for you uh what do you think about the
move F3 do you want to suck to Paul I
don't want to Saku rise upon uh
who do you think I am
uh the problem you're offering me would
you like to take it right if you play
hey well F5 you're doing me the greatest
favor I'll tell you why because in my
opinion this Pawn on G4 oops excuse me
this Pawn on G4 is a potential Target
you can always go
eat right so here
I'm not saying I'm drawing the game or
anything like that on the contrary I
don't like my position at least I'm
fighting my way back the problem for me
is that if you play after F3 takes I
have to play King of one
and you play Rook here and you go check
I have to play here
and
I don't like it but from the very
beginning the problem for me at uh bacon
is that after F3 you play this one yeah
that's really a nasty move yeah right
uh I think Benjamin could simply be
strategically losing and we still like
Benjamin wasn't inspired to play today
after yesterday's game I think this is
the biggest issue yesterday you just
feel like you just lost you know he was
having a great tournament and then after
that lawsuit I feel like he had just
lost his motivation well and it's hard
to coach
show up and actually play yeah come back
after a heartbreaker like that the other
thing is F3 is not working yeah
yeah so a second possibility for
Benjamin as a way of Defense
is you need to get your king out of the
back rank
I know it's weird but it could
[Music]
I know in the i in the sense to try you
set up for this right yeah and then most
probably I'm gonna lose H2 pawn and then
exchange B to a pawn
well anything just try to hold that
position right uh this is what I meant
when I was saying that the pawn on G4
from me is a target so whenever I see F5
I I you're happy I'm well happy is
relative at least you get a grateful
thanks uh you can see more clearly why I
think uh the pawn is vulnerable once you
see so far it seems like it's totally
lost unfortunately it feels like sassy
is in great shape a game I'm kind of
surprised isn't over because we thought
that John Burke was winning easily it
was against Mishra Mishra is still in
there he's throwing the patties I don't
know what Zach we left it right here
and it looked overwhelming
but Mishra said okay I've got some
tricks don't think you can just take my
Pawn
Rook C2 Sims winning though right
borrowing a
yeah yeah
exactly I Let's Dance that's interesting
you suggested which would meet which
was met with rookest one yeah he's
making the route to stay on City and
then playing Rook at eight yeah but
there's a the difference is the partners
on age three so that's between B3 and
like B8 works it's unlike that position
we were talking about
a moment ago but yes we've got
everything covered
there's no puppet
there's no Perpetual check because the
queen is patrolling this beautiful
diagonal E5 should be winning now
centralized the crane exactly anytime
you have these opportunities of a very
powerfully uh centralized queen queen E5
check followed by Rook takes G2 that
looks maybe Queen
G3 Queen
tell us what you're thinking uh I was
thinking maybe Yuko was the king the
problems that were if you've got to go
to the background right okay the idea is
that if you take on G2 then Queen H6
foreign
[Music]
check on H6 again King G4
I think so Queen on E5 is lovely that's
the whole point what you pointed out
from the very beginning the queen on E5
dominates uh all kinds of checks usually
what uh in such situations I try not to
calculate that much I'm like Quinn
yeah Queen goes to a good Square uh
let's see what John's technique is he's
simply saying well you know what I'm
just going to walk my king across and
this is also absolutely winning position
absolutely winning absolutely winning
and for John
um
he
suffered because yesterday he had a game
against Nicholas that turned around John
was actually if he hadn't played the
queen D6 if he had played the queen E7
idea
he might be uh completely so different
situation so he uh John Burke that is to
say uh he showed up to play today unlike
Benjamin uh and you know he's doing it
in a tough circumstance that he he he
lost a winning game yesterday we expect
King D1 oh he played I expect
resignation very soon King is escaping
you can see from our uh webcams that uh
Mishra is really suffering absolutely
he's not happy I'll be my news
so we might see a number of Victories
here we we have one already
um by the way interviewers big shout out
to the players and I mean that's
sincerely
um
when you're in a tournament it's like
you're so focused you've got tunnel
vision it's all about the tournament
it's all about your preparation it's all
about getting in the nutrition it's all
about getting in your exercise you don't
want to hear there's a birthday party
and you don't want to hear come for an
interview
so uh our thanks to the players for
being uh Cooperative in in joining us
and then I do believe many of
happy to be interviewed they're excited
about it
well I don't know I mean I if I were
then if I were in their shoes I'd say
get get get yeah sir
I want to talk to Vegas
I want to talk to her not to that guy I
mean let's go let's go uh but any in any
case John's looking great here as uh he
puts on the finishing touches and we saw
it's just something to see players
losing
now another thing uh why I really like
your move Queen E5 much earlier is not
only because it protected our King which
was great but it also means that the
opposing Queen doesn't get to play he
looks like Queen C5 again
the whole the whole board right it's
such a lovely move to
move I know you just make uh here well
I'm I'm not one for trading pawns or
anything like that here I would be very
uh much inclined to playing the move
Rook C2 if I could to be honest I think
Queen B8 is immediately winning even
Queen B8 King G7 yep and I can't walk I
just I need to optimize my queen d8
yep
Queen E6 yep
and it just took an E4 simple
I like that I like that before it's
great yeah this uh we we kind of call it
a Stairway a series of checks where the
queen comes no I mean whether the queen
is on E5 or whether the queen is on e4
uh centralized squares I'm gonna control
everything exactly and then after taking
on e4 especially uh was the King on G7
if he's going to check a lot at some
point I can play Queen E5 for Queen D4
interposing so for something like uh
just as to repeat what begin is saying
is whenever you get the check you can
interpose yes nice
nice so John is well on his way again we
think Benjamin uh
Benjamin had to because the F3 ideas
were not working he's he wants to play
King A1 and on a good day he's hoping
that he could trade this Pawn I think I
love you I think as you said he
mentioned I love your idea King episode
and King G6 as many yes he's not on time
to play A4 A5 and control the G5 square
right uh just let's see it uh just go
down the Primrose path because it's so
darn forcing right F5
you're checkmating me
and then
[Laughter]
who's checkmating whom
uh check meeting check meeting
um
that is not easy well you get the H2
pawn it might just be easy it might just
be easy Rook C1
yeah I wonder I can play F3 Texas forget
you know I cannot play no the end game
is lost
yeah I it might just be that the H Pawn
is too far too fast uh type of thing and
it's a very very very forcing line maybe
he will blunder like if I
F5
uh finally once again we have the game
between Amman and akshat it's it's
really really tough uh sledding here for
Action dressings depressing but uh put
put black out of his misery how would
you go about uh
technique what's your Technique here
it's black no with white of course
I'm not gonna suffer
no no I don't I was actually thinking of
a knight of four okay five night H3 so
yeah I'm threatening to play Knight G5
and you have you must come back with
your King on F7 right so my idea was to
make you play H6 right and then come
back provoked H6 and come back on a
foreign exactly okay so the problem is
that you can play Rook C6 instead of
seven let's remind everybody what has
happened already in this round five we
uh take a quick Gander of the standings
beg them do the honors
a so far
there's still one game
we still have one game going which is
akshat versus Arman others pronounce
draw today and so far he's a leader with
three and a half points in Nicholas
Theodore also tying for force was three
and a half points John Burke most
probably is gonna win the round right
Elliott newsnik two and a half and there
he's there is a huge tie for fourth
we're gonna see what will happen and
let's get
it take a look at the big group well in
the B group by the way uh Andrew Han
sitting pretty yeah first place uh How
Sweet It Is it is as we mentioned
already the game between akshat and
Armand is still going but it seems like
Arman is doing
with them Andrew Hong is going to be the
solo leader after five rounds and then
Ty for the second La masseth Chandra and
about surround and others are sharing a
fourth place so monopolis uh as we get
prepared to uh bid a fond Ado I did want
to bring you back because I had you
under the microscope there for a moment
uh you like the move Knight F4 and guess
what he played it he did it he did he
did these guys people listen to me
they're good they're very good uh Knight
F4 and what can I say I hate
walking into your idea I think that
that's a very powerful idea that you
want to see him play H6 so you can go
back and go night here night here so I
can't play uh ball I have to go back
with my Rook to easy and the problem is
six is a knight H5 Knight H5
which immediately hurt
and you cannot protect okay now teach
yourself
let's just stop pause here for just a
moment because the night however long it
is it's just it's temporarily a little
bit inconvenient before
okay and
[Music]
after I will let you check my ones nope
nope it's not so it's terrible
essentially the desirable Rook C6 walks
into Knight H5 and King F7 walks into
Knight H3 maybe that no yeah maybe
that's the time people are looking 86
maybe it feels like it but night the
problem is that Knight G5 and then H7 is
hanging as well as E7 is on a tap as
well it sounds like if he finds Knight
H3 he's winning yes
and uh I I suspect he will uh however
once yesterday we had left a game that
was completely winning for Benjamin uh
we were were shocked when the result
went the opposite way by the way again
this is a big game act shot he came into
this round uh with high expectations if
he loses he loses his grip on first
place but we will see tomorrow as we uh
get ready to close our show we want to
say that thank you so much for joining
us each and every day you're welcome to
join us at four o'clock Central Time
here in St Louis and there's a thing you
can do for us a nice favor tell
everybody tell your friends where you're
hanging out
subscribe to the St Louis chess club and
tell them a little bit more about
positions tell us tell them how
cauliflower St Louis chess club will
have all the information about the
tournament right
and isn't there a way that they can
subscribe or something yeah following
subscribing is the same subscribe is
like for YouTube
thank you so much for joining us and
begin thank you yes you're doing great
baby we'll see you tomorrow we'll see
you tomorrow as well good night
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited